the UK government and Health Care unions
have come to a final payoffer which
could end strikes affecting the National
Health Service the offer to unions
representing nurses and ambulance
workers includes additional pay for next
year unions have already voiced a mixed
reaction to this offer and the deal does
not cover Junior doctors who are also
holding strikes Harry Fawcett is in
London so Harry what is this offer what
is this tentative deal that's on the
table and tell us more about the early
reactions to it
well as you say it's not a deal fully
done yet but it is a major offer and it
does look like a major step forward in
this very damaging industrial dispute
that's been going on and really
disrupting the National Health Service
uh what it offers is on top of the four
percent pay rise for last year uh which
was already vetted in there is a further
two percent uh one-off bonus payment for
all of these staff they are as you say
ambulance workers paramedics nurses and
support staff cleaners security guards
and the like that's more than a million
people and on top of that bonus there
will be another bonus of at least
fifteen hundred dollars per person uh
they're calling that an NHS backlog
bonus a payment to reward staff for
helping the service come out of the
covid-19 pandemic and so that represents
about another four percent on average we
believe so that's about a six percent
bonus on top of a four percent pay rise
for last year pretty much dealing with
the kind of inflationary right rises in
cost of living that people have been
seeing and for the next financial year
which starts next month April there'll
be a five percent regular pay rise as
well so that is something that most of
the unions involved have put uh to are
putting to their their members that they
are supporting uh certainly the big
three which is very important if their
members vote in favor then it is pretty
much destined to go through there is one
unit the United Union which says it
won't support these but of course there
are lots of other industrial disputes
going on throughout the public sector as
well just today there are further
strikes going on with transport workers
teachers are still out on strike as well
the head of the office for Budget
responsibility that the independent sort
of forecaster and financial Watchdog for
the government it says that if all of
these unions get the same kind of deal
that could be more than 13 billion
dollars that the government has to find
Harry Fawcett in London thank you very
much